this video is sponsored by software keep
get your Microsoft products at a
discounted price Apple's 15-inch MacBook
Air is finally here and it just got a
bit more confusing to choose which
MacBook to buy especially deciding if
it's worth going up to the high-end
MacBook Pros for a higher price or
simply choosing the 13 inch air which
has a brand new lower price well in this
MacBook buyers guide I'm going to walk
you through the value proposition of
each MacBook in Apple's lineup and who
each one is meant for but first I want
to go through the key differences
between the current 13-inch M2 air and
the new 15-inch model the main
difference is of course the 15.3 inch
display giving it about 30 percent more
screen real estate than the 13 inch
model which is honestly enough to make
this thing a whole lot more useful for
multitasking and having multiple web
pages open at once now the surprising
thing is that the battery life is quoted
at the same 18 hours even though the
battery itself off is 26 percent larger
66.5 Watt hours instead of 52.6 and
that's because it has to run exactly 26
more total pixels in terms of resolution
so the math checks out now instead of
having a four speaker system like on the
13-inch model the 15 inch air gets a
six-speaker system just like the higher
end MacBook Pros which I think will make
a huge difference in the speaker quality
so you're basically getting all of that
for just two hundred dollars more than
the 13 inch model right well actually no
you're getting even more some people
might not have noticed this but the 15
inch model actually comes with the
unbend 10 core GPU at the same 12.99
base price now if you were to upgrade
that GPU the 13 inch model actually
comes with a bend a core so if you
upgrade it to the 10 core there would
only be a 100 difference which I'd say
is 100 percent worth spending for the
larger display and better speakers but
going even further the 15 inch air comes
with Apple's new 35 watt dual Port
charger in the box which is actually a
20 upgrade on the 13 inch model and let
me tell you that difference is
definitely worth it since you get an
additional port to charge your iPhone or
iPad or anything else so in reality when
you match them spec for spec the 15 inch
model is really only eighty dollars more
and I honestly can't believe that Apple
packed that much value in for that
thirteen hundred dollar price and I
think it's gonna sell like crazy and
everyone looking should just go for the
15 inch model if you care about getting
the best value however there are
actually three reasons why some people
should simply go for the 13 inch model
instead but before I get into that if
you're a Mac or a Windows user who does
any sort of work with documents
spreadsheet sheets or slideshows our
sponsor software keep is giving our
viewers 25 off on genuine Microsoft
software like a one-time purchase of
Microsoft Office for Mac or Windows
which includes word excel and PowerPoint
now there are so many fishy websites out
there that could scam you but software
keep is a Microsoft certified partner
who sells only 100 genuine Microsoft
software so you don't have to worry
which resulted in software keep earning
over a hundred thousand five star
reviews they also have great prices on
other software including the most
popular antivirus software out there and
their customer service is phenomenal
with 24 7 365 customer support where
you'll talk to a real person instead of
a robot so if you have any questions
they'll be glad to help so buy Microsoft
Office for Mac windows or anything else
you need today and save 25 off their
already great prices by using the link
in the description and the coupon code
mtyt25 now getting back to why some
people should choose use the 13 inch
instead first of all the entry price is
200 cheaper than the 15 inch which is
definitely a good savings for reason
number two if you don't care about
graphics performance for things like
gaming and productivity work then the a
core GPU model will be just fine as you
can see in this performance chart it's
still more than fast enough for most
people now for reason number three the
13 inch is definitely more portable
since the 15 has a 24 larger footprint
and it weighs 22 percent more 3.3 pounds
instead of 2.7 so if you do a lot of
traveling or you're a student the
difference might be enough for you to
choose the 13 inch over the larger 15.
so to be honest the only reason I would
recommend getting the 13 inch air
instead of the 15 is if you care more
about portability then value for
everybody else seriously just buy the
new 15-inch MacBook Air now apple is
also also selling the Third 18 inch
MacBook Pro with the old design and in
my opinion absolutely zero people on
Earth should buy this thing it's the
same price as the new 15 inch air but is
worse in so many different ways just
don't buy it yes it has a fan to cool
the M2 Chip but honestly the fanless M2
air handles heat just fine unless you're
really pushing both the CPU and GPU at
the same time and now the 15 inch air
has a larger chassis which will help
dissipate heat better so please do not
buy the 13-inch MacBook Pro now before I
get into the Dilemma of buying the 15
inch air or the 14 and 16 inch MacBook
Pro Models I've got to mention the
classic and legendary M1 MacBook Air yes
it's got the old design and the big
bezels and it lacks Max safe and many
other features but you can literally buy
one for only 800 brand new on Amazon
right now making it a killer deal for
someone on a more limited budget so I
still recommend the M1 Air at that price
for those looking to save the most
amount of money possible but if you have
extra cash laying around seriously just
go for the new 15-inch air and now we
have to introduce the 14 and 16 inch
MacBook Pro Models which are definitely
a tougher sell for Apple now that you
can get such a large 15 inch display on
a MacBook Air honestly I believe that
most consumers will be just fine with
the new 15-inch air in terms of
everything from display immersivity
performance reliability quality and
convenience but there are definitely a
few reasons to grab one of the higher
end Pros instead so let's start off with
the 14 inch model the biggest reason is
the value proposition because even
though it seems like the 14 inch is 700
more expensive than the 15 inch air
that's not counting the fact that the
pro already comes with an upgraded 512
gig SSD and 6 18 gigs of RAM both of
which are faster than what you get with
the M2 air so that brings the difference
in price down to just three hundred
dollars however we've seen the 14 inch
M2 pro model on sale on Amazon as low as
eighteen hundred dollars bringing the
difference to just a hundred bucks if
you do in fact want an upgraded SSD and
RAM on the 15 inch air now yes the 14
inch display is a bit smaller than the
15 but it comes with a huge amount of
advantages including my all-time
favorite which is 120 hertz Pro motion
display Tech which makes the screen look
twice as smooth matching the experience
of promotion on new pro model iPhones
which I really value there's also the
xdr display which can go up to 1600 nits
of brightness for HDR content on the 14
inch MacBook Pro which the 15 inch of
course can't get since it's hard limited
to 500 nits the 14 18 inch MacBook Pro
also gets additional ports including
HDMI SD card slot and an extra
Thunderbolt Port as well as likely
better speakers microphones Wi-Fi 6E
support and it comes with a faster 67
watt charger in the box but the biggest
reason to go for the higher end MacBook
Pros is of course the M2 Pro and Max
chips which offer a huge boost in
performance even the base model Bend 10
core CPU on the pro is 35 faster than
the M2 Chip and you of course have the
option to upgrade to the 12 core which
gets even faster and in terms of
graphics performance the M2 Pro chip is
over two times faster so if you really
care about getting the most performance
you can get the extra cash is definitely
worth it and it gets even better with
the M2 Max chip upgrades that take the
performance Sky High as well as the
larger 16 inch model if you want to
really go all out so I would say that
the only reason anyone really go for the
14 or 16 inch MacBook Pro Models is if
you already plan on upgrading to a 512
gig SSD and 16 gigs of RAM which the
pros get automatically and you would
also like to take advantage of those
extra ports and extra performance other
than that I'd say that the 15-inch
MacBook Air will cover the performance
needs of most people out there the only
thing you should be aware of is that
we're still expecting the 15 inch air to
have the same single nand SSD issue as
the 13-inch model had which could lead
to drastically slower performance during
heavy multitasking and productivity
workloads so there you guys go that was
our buyer's guide for all of the new
MacBooks in 2023 including the new
15-inch model so if you enjoyed it click
that Circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one and definitely
check out our take on Apple's new Vision
Pro thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
foreign